and more in this flash crash case and
what this guy did spoofing layering we
might need a crash course and what that
means exactly what these trades are
Bloomberg's Finance reporter Cary Geiger
has a quick explainer for us Cary hey
Betty
so spoofing is an interesting market
structure issue basically traders will
flood the market with the intention of
them with orders of a certain security
with the intention of them canceling
those orders and what that does is it
artificially drives the price of that
security up or down and it puts all the
other traders that are working you know
basically looking to trade that security
in a frenzy and it just creates a very
false price and demand and output for
that security and under the dodd-frank
law which was passed in 2010 smoothly
became very illegal so to speak and we
have not seen a lot of criminal activity
with spoofing cases we saw the first big
one last year under the US Attorney's
Office in Chicago with Michael Kousaka
so this case is another landmark
crinimal criminal spoofing case that
we're seeing coming out of the US
Attorney's Office now okay so so that's
spoofing what about layering Cary well
basically it's similar it's a similar
type of thing where you take different
orders you take you know basically you
flood the market with orders and
basically what you're trying to do is
hide your intentions on whether you're
going to buy and sell a specific stock
and again it creates a false sense of
whether that sock stock is going to be
bought or sold and then the market will
artificially drive that price up or down
so it's basically just another type of
market manipulation